this was as much a display of national
mourning as it was the North Korean
ruling class puffing out his chest
images meant for the outside world and
indeed for its own people
at the center of it all one man amongst
maybe a meal kim jong hoon kim jong il's
son his successor a man we know so
little about the death of one dictator
and the succession of another tends to
leave a country in a fragile state but
also a volatile one new dictators have a
point to prove not just to the rest of
the world but also to their beleaguered
citizens market economies and aluminum
so little clearly loves Jung ko phangan
pantheism holy Toledo we solemnly
pledged this general says to achieve
with guns the lifetime wishes of the
founding father kim eel soul and General
Kim Jong heel that is the historical
achievements of unification is this the
approved strategy of the world's newest
dictator or a forced foreign policy put
upon a puppet leader it's really too
hard to tell
Pyongyang streets were deserted for a
second day in North Korea you can hardly
afford to be the one person not to turn
up to the great leaders funeral a three
minute silence was observed impeccably
broken at the end by the sounding of
ships horns and factory sirens
Yong Kim jong-un is North Korea's new
leader the now seemed little doubt of
that politician followed by general
spoke to endorse him but he himself said
nothing and remains an unknown his
father now laid to rest the man who is
not yet 30 will want to make his mark
and define the next chapter of this
revered dynasty Alice of Uncle Sky News